one part of the expose claimed that
during the filming of the red light
Greenlight game some contestants
successfully crossed the Finish Line
only to still get eliminated their incfi
squid packs which simulate gunshots and
Signal a contestants elimination
allegedly exploded way after the fact
that group didn't take it well one
contestant recalled it really wasn't a
game show it was a TV show and we were
basically extras in a TV show not only
were filming conditions during one
specific game reportedly horrible but
some former contestants made claims that
the entire thing was rigged for their
part Netflix and its co-producing Studio
Partners deny claims of a fixed game
telling Rolling Stone any suggestion
that the competition is rigged or claims
of serious harm to players are simply
untrue we've taken all the appropriate
safety precautions including after care
for contestants and an independent
adjudicator is overseeing each game to
ensure its fair to everyone